[Applause]
the assault on free and fair elections
is just such a threat
literally i've said it before
we're facing the most significant test
of our democracy
since the civil war that's not hyperbole
since the civil war
the confederates back then never
breached the capital
as insurrectionists did on january the
6th
perhaps you should consult
merriam-webster on the meaning of
hyperbole it's an assault on democracy
to allow an extra hour
of required early voting in texas two to
three
hours longer by the way than joe's home
state of delaware
the white house invited fraudster al
sharpton an assorted racial activist to
participate in its voting rights
performance in philadelphia
now it was kind of an odd choice of
venue given that it's the place where
democrats believe all those white racist
men
got together during the racist
constitutional convention
president biden spoke for 25 minutes or
so and told
about the same number of lies about the
supposed impediments to voting in the
united states
all of course created or tolerated by
republicans in texas for example
republican-led state legislature wants
to allow partisan poll watchers
to intimidate voters and imperil and
impartial uh poll workers they want
voters
to dive further and be able to be in a
position where they wonder who's
watching them
and intimidating them to wait longer to
vote
to drive a hell of a lot they want to
make it so hard and inconvenient
that they hope people don't vote at all
yeah inconvenient to cheating mr
president
now i believe i counted four maybe five
lies there but for the record the texas
legislation gives poll watchers free
movement
except of course contrary to what biden
alleged not when voters are filling out
ballots
and forcing poll watchers to stand at
such a distance that they couldn't
reasonably
observe the process would be a criminal
offense you got to have
eyes on potential cheating now this
texas proposal makes total sense given
what happened in some states last
november
remember poll watchers who were kept on
the other side of the room behind a rope
unable to conduct any meaningful
oversight that can't happen
but as usual liberals are at war with
the facts
joe's just reading whatever script his
writers handed him desperately trying to
get people to step
into their big top state legislators
want to make it harder for you to vote
and if you vote
they want to be able to tell your vote
doesn't count
for any reason they make up so
dramatic also totally false as we
pointed out last week
the texas bills expand voting hours for
all registered voters and the bills even
lower the population threshold
needed for counties to provide
additional
early voting hours oh terrible
now notice that none of these democrats
ever mention
the actual specifics of the legislation
well we know why because to do so would
expose their phony complaints
i want to get right to the point here
democrats want to rig every election
going forward to make it nearly
impossible for a conservative to win
again
there now effectively arguing that the
very voting rules that delivered
two two-term victories for bill clinton
and barack obama
are essentially just like jim crow 2.0
there weren't months of early voting
back then there was no flood of
unsolicited mail and ballot applications
arriving at your home
there was no rampant ballot harvesting
obviously no same-day voter registration
and yet democrats
somehow still managed to win under those
old rules
but five and a half years after obama
left office democrats
are seeing their edge with minority
voters starting to wane
more hispanics entrepreneurial and
optimistic
are recognizing the left-wing war
against prosperity
black men are also beginning to
recognize that liberal pandering
doesn't help their kids education or job
prospects
these trend lines are terrible for
democrats
they know that their policies aren't
going to deliver results to entry-level
working-class americans
not in urban areas not anywhere
so this leaves them really with only one
option in their mind which is
to promote racial fear mongering in
pretty much everything around them
so we already know what they're doing in
our schools to our workplaces
the military even to now our system of
voting
they're trying not only targeting
people of color they're targeting voters
of all races and backgrounds
with a simple target who did not vote
for them
that's the target it's hard to declare
just how critical this
is it's simply unconscionable
i love how he says things slowly for
emphasis and tries to pull them out of
there
now what's unconscionable is to use your
bully pulpit to lie about race
to talk down to blacks and hispanics and
to imply that they're not savvy enough
somehow
to make a photocopy of their own id
madam vice president
the fact is democrats used covid
to change the way we all voted all along
with the intent of making those new
rules permanent
the new voting normal with states
getting wise though to their sleight of
hand
liberals are growing more desperate and
sloppy
the act it's just not that convincing
anymore
we're going to face another test in 2022
a new wave of unprecedented voter
suppression
and raw and sustained election
subversion
we have to prepare now as i said time
and again
no matter what you can never stop the
american people from voting
now if they could start harvesting
ballots right now
for 2022 and 2024 they would
they've been upfront about wanting to
eliminate all voter id
requirements which they argue are
inherently racist
they even want to prevent the regular
scrubbing of dead voters or voters who
move from the rolls
they did that remember in florida and
georgia and you'd think that police were
firing water cannons and voters heading
to the polls the way they described it
so as usual democrats they're going for
stunts
over substance to get you to believe
the fantasy that voter id is just as
discriminatory as poll taxes and
literary
literacy tests they have to drown you in
hype and phony emotion complete
with their own score but singing on key
is of course optional
we will overcome we will
[Music]
i do believe
[Music]
i don't think they advanced to the next
round
and as the day wore on the performances
grew lamer
all they're trying to do is is suppress
the vote and encumber
um usually people that aren't as
economically well-off
people that are of color and and that's
what the state of texas is starting to
look like it's starting to look
a little too colorful for the
republicans uh sorry jasmine
but in texas the gop expanded
its support among latinos
whoops now we know what the left prefers
they want rules that give them unlimited
time to count and deliver votes
days weeks and even months after the
polls close
therefore the people act that they were
touting today
is more accurately described as for the
liberals act
it would mandate same-day or automatic
voter registration which
obviously opens up the door to rampant
fraud possibilities and
vote by mail would be a staple
they even want to force the supreme
court to change
its ethics rules if they end up hearing
any election challenge
so fast forward now would you to the day
after the 2022 election and
republicans have let's say retaken the
house they may
added a few senate seats democrats who
railed against trump for not accepting
the outcome
of the last election will i promise you
spend the next two years
claiming the midterms were illegitimate
then we'll get the same tired acts
leading up to 2024.
the three-ring circus it was only
exciting when the talent could deliver
oohs and oz but the democrats
have become just one big overpriced
clown show
hardly worth their high price of
admission
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else